some people spend their Saturdays going
for it
others going nowhere living on the edge
or looking at a hedge the members of the
dull men's club don't give the matter a
second thought I think it's a nice thing
to be Darla - I mean that the slogan of
the club is celebrating the ordinary I
think it's quite trendy to be dull and
we start in a bit of a cult movement if
you like by being dull twelve members of
the dull men's club and their odd
hobbies have been immortalized in the
club's own calendar the 2015 edition
features among others Hugh Barker the
hedge watcher and Steve wheeler the milk
bottle collector he's got close to
20,000 even though he doesn't especially
like milk there's a postbox spotter and
a man with the world's biggest
collection of traffic cones
Kevin Beresford of Birmingham is mr.
January the Lord of the Rings as he's
called is president of the UK roundabout
appreciation society there's nothing
more expressive than the one way
gyratory you can put anything kind of
roundabout and I've seen paintings
statues trains boats planes pubs
churches even working windmills anything
you'd like I can go on a roundabout and
I think that's what makes them so
special Hugh Barker keeps abreast of
henges not the funds but the shrubs he's
even written a book about them hedges
are surprisingly important parts of our
landscape I'm partly interested in for
symbolic reasons and partly because of
all the strange ways that people cut
their hedges into funny shapes what how
you cut your head says about you and
things like that so it's a bit it's a
bit of a bit of the silly stuff and a
bit of quite serious stuff that
underlies it as well
the book and Hugh bark at the epithet
London's dullest man in the British
media but he has no problem with that a
lot of the things that people are
interested in might seem very strange
and but a lot of people have these
quirky interests and a lot of them are
men and I don't think there's anything
wrong with it I think it's something to
be proud of not the calendar was the
brainchild of Leland Carlsen an American
who founded the dull men's club 30 years
ago in New York and later brought it to
the UK this is its first calendar and
it's already put the club in the
spotlight but the dull men often feel
misunderstood the news pick it up they
say the dullest men
we're not the dullest I mean that's kind
of extreme dull
we're just dull we would some of us
aren't trying to be the duller than
anyone else celebrating the ordinary
just be content with ordinary simple
things in life is a lot better than
going skydiving for example I think a
lot of Israeli just taken out the club
estimates its worldwide membership and
around 5,000 newcomers are always
welcomed the admission requirements are
easy the calendar includes a membership
certificate we were rather proud of this
design and it's a lovely two-tone grey
with a touch of beige around the edge to
her favorite colors many Britons dream
of their little slice of ho-hum at least
to judge by what London's calendar
sellers have to say we've put sell
thousands of counters a week from where
as usually our best seller at the moment
it taps into the eccentricity of
individuals but I think English people
like that sort of humour have been
looking at that but really pleased so
far alongside the other currants we've
gotten as similar titles on previous
years have done well and I think this
year this would be easily our number one
leaving the humor aside the doll men
just may have hit a nerve or soothe the
nerve in an often fast-paced high stress
world a psychologist Mark Coulson sees
it the dull men and they're anything but
exciting interests have a certain
contemplative almost therapeutic appeal
there are some research findings that
suggest
if you have a limited set of interests
if you limit what it is that concerns
you then this simple life is actually a
happy life that's in today's society we
just presented with too many choices
there are too many options as a result
sometimes stepping outside of that frame
and say well what I'm going to be
concerned about is what got what I find
passion in this may be a very direct
route to happiness is this what happy
men look like the dull men don't go
chasing after the latest fashion or
thrill but their unerring pursuit of
their interests certainly brings a smile
to other people's faces in a way we're
the avant-garde movement we push out the
envelope people might think we're
daubrey in a way we're the opposite but
were groundbreakers if so look forward
to an even less exciting but highly
coveted calendar next year